bon moi je ne fais pas ça d'accord moi
mon travail c'est de bien après donc les
gens elle vient me voir mon mari est
parti ma femme est partie mon corps ma
copine et partez vous le renvoyons
urbain
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ont prié pour moi oui ok ils vont
revenir à la maison d'accord voilà
d'accord et là ils reviennent oui non
non non 80% et allait venir danser
incroyable donc je vais expliquer
aujourd'hui marabout c'est quelque chose
très bien sûr il ya des faux marabout
oui il ya des vrais moments c'est que ça
fout embrouiller ne sait au quai
gambetta non là il ya des inquiétudes
chez les gens c'est pour ça et bill je
suis marabout et pas du tout mais sont
pas de compétence comme tout le domaine
comment alors on peut pas le savoir si
on vend ses ambitions que de le laisser
en fait
si on fait pas si on va en voir un on
peut pas savoir en fait c'est ça dépend
des résultats voilà ça descend des
résultats et la façon qu'il va faire les
consultations et la façon qu'il va te
parme et botro passe et comment ça se
passe par une consultation par exemple
voilà géant vous voir je vous dit
j'aimerais voilà qu'un chroniqueurs
reviennent mon meilleur ski partie par
rachid arhab
mais
puisque vous faites revenir les gens
écoutent pas que ça pourrait faire
partir des gens si qui sont magnifiques
non ça ça dépend non donc ça dépend de
la personne qui va venir le marabout
c'est pas un dieu ouais c'est ça ma
personne iman d'accord s'il plaît - si
je peux faire quelque chose je vous dis
tout de suite je peux faire d'accord si
je peux pas je te dis je préfère voilà
parce que je suis pas dieu mais je
demande dur qui vous demandez je demande
à dieu d'accord voilà on travaille avec
l'ondé mal de dieu ont fait la prière
avec le don avec le grand-père et les
esprits donc en fait vous appelez
d'abord le rendement en terre oui qui
appelle ensuite dès qu'ils en village
donc il ya
des fois on edge et parfois on veut
faire les
impôts de demain qui venaient nous voir
le stade - de viol oui je sais mais je
sais danser pas la raison non mais je
vous dis moi pour professeur jouer ni
moi j'ai même des gens très très proches
moi qui font appel à des marabouts
parfois oui pour voilà parce qu'ils ont
envie de voilà de faire revenir
quelqu'un parce qu'ils sont dans des
ruptures parce qu'ils ont perdu leur
travail parce qu'ils ont perdu plein de
choses ont perdu leur client a bien dû
s'éclater dans le deuxième tiroir à
droite
a trouvé les clés mimi meilleur parti
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai alors
il ya une école de marabouts ou comment
ça se passe sur la mare à boue school
là maintenant mais c'est vrai que c'est
le sens qu'on ai marre vous vous sentez
que vous avez un don spécial 500 et vous
pouvez communiquer avec les avec avec le
vol avec loin de lambiner avait avec le
avancer mon grand-père arrière grand
père arrière grand père qui a fait et
les thèmes et porté en france ici au
moment de la guerre 1944 ouais on est
soirée dans le double take fera quatre
ans on remettra oui oui mon grand père
vous êtes de quelle origine moi ce dîner
dit tout bas ce serait mon grand-père et
s'appelle elhadj karama diaby touba a
dîné à leur ordinateur et à khartoum a
et à toumaï guinée à tous masse au
sénégal et à tous ma quoi de voir et à
touba omani il ya tout va bien
ça va je voulais dire c'est qu'elle est
marabout d'abord les vrais marabo sont
extrêmement respectée et assurée
position comme des sages des bien sûr et
ils font appel aux esprits des ancêtres
en général vous pourrez faire évoluer
les choses je crois que ça alors c'est
ça est ce que est ce que est ce que vous
avez eu des chants connus qui sont venus
vous voir pour vous demander voilà des
choses par rapport à d'autres personnes
non même si vous mais dis moi je n'ai
pas doit faire le mal à quelqu'un n'est
pas le droit non ça ça marche jamais non
je n'ai jamais c'est du passé récent la
sphère peu bas on dit que paul pogba
aurait été voir un marabout pour jeter
un sort kylie ann mbps qu'il ya des
marabouts qui le font ok je connais pas
un marabout qui fait le mal est fait on
confond dit le marabout et le fait
tisseyre elle n'est pas la même souche
de quoi effectivement le féticheur et à
des marabouts et à des féticheurs
féticheur voilà
deux différents mais plupart en france
ici c'est le marabout qui sont là qui
prix qu'ils demandent à la même s'il ya
des problèmes en france par exemple le
temps de couvrir de nous on s'est réuni
40 marabout a récité la prière pour
lequel le maladie il va partir le plus
vite et alors ce que c'est nous toujours
quand il démarre en quelle année
le temps de latence week-end et
cailhavel aux maladies voilà parce que
ça c'est ça c'est marquer quand il ya
les sky à quelque chose qui est venu en
grave et faute de mandela pour qu'il
soit aidé pour que ça va repartir plus
vite possible et donc le féticheur cv
qui fait la magie noire soit la magie
noire cette
honte on va en parler juste parce qu'on
va parler de cette affaire pogba aussi
juste jean-didier vous êtes spécialiste
du surnaturel peut-être voyant également
mais thierry médium d'accord pas je suis
témoin ces mots là
[Rires]
est ce que la sorcellerie ça existe ah
oui on est sûr c'est vrai ça existe
depuis la nuit des temps comme on l'a
dit comme on l'a expliqué il ya des gens
qui font le bien et des gens qui font de
mal effectivement il ya des marabouts
la seule chose sur laquelle je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord c'est qu'il ya
quand même certains qui font de mal je
te jure professeur dit malraux moi j'ai
une une personne qui m'a dit qu'elle
avait été voir un marabout pour faire du
mal à une autre personne sexy oui ça
existe ça existe ça existe benjamin
castaldi sur bernard montiel
c'est vrai mais ça existe alors monsieur
lui il a l'air d'avoir des intentions
tué sur scène 6h10 ma il est sain oui
c'est vrai après son discours en tout
cas non je sonnais passera les tests je
ne vous connais pas personnellement ça
fait poliment cette affaire pourquoi il
a fait polémique hier sur bfm tv mais il
a fait polémique parce que il révèle des
pratiques la rationalité des français
alors c'est quoi les pratiques est ce
qu'on peut y arriver dit les pratiques
par exemple c'est la protection il faut
le dire énormément de sportifs français
de joueurs de foot ont un marabout de
protection des intérêts des dizaines qui
font appel à un marabout comme paul
pogba qui l'a reconnu un accord pour
empêcher les blessures ah oui c'est ça
ouais ça c'est le bien la serbie alors
là c'est le protection simplement parce
que sa fille s'était dit peu surpris moi
j'ai par exemple connu je peux pas vous
dire le nom mais un marabout qui allait
c'est en ligue 2 donc au niveau du
football français qui allaient sur des
terrains de football planté d enterrer
des choses au pied des poteaux pour que
l'équipe qu'il défend dès le lendemain
soit protégée et que l'adversaire ne
marque pas oui mais il me disait
t'inquiète pas on encaissera pas de but
demain ça marchait à chaque fois
dans le milieu lui faire ça veut pas
faire ça dans le paddock
m non je suis un tournoi bientôt c'est
vrai qu'on
avait que le président michel denisot
qui était président du psg à l'époque en
2014 voilà lors d'un la veille d'un
match de ligue des champions il a payé
un marabout 500 euros pour gagner le oui
j'ai
baissé ma roue d'ailleurs parce que
j'aimerais amener le ce qu'on trouve
dans la presse sur internet et il ya une
vidéo il a fait toute une émission télé
dans l'activité hippique que dont il
était dirigeant du psg il avait fait
intervenir un marabout ça marche ou pas
desservis marché
se qualifier et je pense que ce marabout
était aussi médium puisqu'il avait même
dit le score il avait donné le score du
match il a dit vous avez gagné 5 à 0 et
ils ont gagné 5 à 0 mais il a fait
encore plus fort parce qu'il a dit il a
marqué trois buts
il a dit quel joueur allait marquer et à
gand laquelle le quai de
l'euromillions 102 cm vous avez les
numéros de l'euro millions alors moi
j'ai fait gagner des personnes oui j'ai
écrit un livre on n'a pas bien
j'aime bien porter béchir est
allé gagné 9,5 millions d'euros
vu l'état vu les nouveaux amis l'épreuve
alors ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on
avait au fait une émission sur m6 qui a
été squizzée parce que a priori ça
plaisait pas trop la française des jeux
non mais t'inquiète pas ce que
j'avais fait on efface tout
donc effectivement on a tourné cette
émission et puis comme un fait et c'est
quoi une histoire c'est papa c'est quoi
l'histoire c'est vraiment l'histoire
c'est que moi j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle le pouvoir magique les pierres
et des cristaux j'utilise beaucoup les
pierres et les cristaux pour gagner
au loto pour acheter une maison pour
obtenir un crédit
[Musique]
pascal est folle il a fait gagner de 5
cm donc là écrit après effectivement
quand elle a utilisé ses rituels et m'a
envoyé l'épreuve en biseau voilà
effectivement j'ai grâce à vous j'ai
gagné 9 millions
sans rituel qui est dans le livre qu'on
a fait a expliqué que j'avais constaté
bordel
ils sont où ces cristaux mais c'est vrai
donc quoi tu as fait un truc et élaguer
est là et tu l'as fait jouer les bons
numéros voilà ou alors au mignon mignon
n'avait pas pensé à ça marche pas parce
que je suis pas destiné à gagner de
l'argent donc moi je suis là je suis
bénévole maintenant ça pourrait marcher
sur quatre ainsi que pour mes droits
d'auteur sur mes livres vous n'êtes pas
avec chaque personne après vous partagez
alors on est on essayait je vais pour un
business et j'ai fait j'ai fait ça j'ai
fait ça avec des gens et
j'avais donné des numéros alors c'était
des petites semaines mais ils ont tous
gagné entre 1000 et 500 et 500 euros on
peut commencer par moi
et pourquoi tu dis pas aux jambes je
vais te faire gagner mais on partage
après alors les gens veulent pas
partager est ce qui est assez bizarre
c'est que quand je dis aux gens je vais
vous aider à gagner et ils y croient pas
les jeux d'une part et me dise où je
vais partager et on va partager les
gains en deux cette fois d'un gagne et
c'est d'un an par 6 juillet elle a gagné
9 millions 10,9 et oignies et là j'ai
zappé aussi sur comment comme
remerciement elle m'a fait un chèque de
150 euros
[Musique]
à cette infamie duvernay
sévit chine vers des ça c'est sûr c'est
incroyable wifi ce qui la zone jamais
dans la sphère foba c'est le marabout du
mal alors on dit que des marabouts
peuvent jeter des sorts par exemple le
frère de paul pogba dit mon frère nuit
jeter un sort à la star qu'il ya même
map et ça monsieur je sais que vous ne
le faites pas mais ça existe bien sûr il
ya même des influenceurs yeux les
interventions moi je sais que ça existe
mais est ce que ça marche le malade pour
boire je ne crois pas une seule seconde
n'y croyais pas non je croyais pas
pourquoi c'est quelqu'un qui est les
croyants mais allez donc vain de la
guinée est
là le président a même eu la russie le
peuple est sorti pour la russie pour sa
maman il fait des choses bien à un dîner
d'accord et l'homme en guinée nm la
france donc on peut il aime l'équipe de
france jeunes en moins chez delcourt à
ça tout à fait d'accord il va faire ça à
ma paie n'y croyais pas du tout
maintenant je voulais voir je pense
qu'il a utilisés certainement entre
guillemets parce que je suis pas dans le
secret des dieux mais je pense que comme
beaucoup de footballeurs comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure aida certainement
utiliser quelqu'un pour se protéger des
blessures à cordes etc ou alors est ce
que gagnent des sommes d'argent
colossales et s'ils sont blessés qui
sont arrêtés pendant des mois c'est donc
à gagner
et donc vous vous la personne a des
ennemis chez nous dans notre coutume et
il dit toujours il faut te protéger
contre tnm c'est combien de consultation
50 euros 50 euros pour faire quoi pour
que tu venais me voir il faut bien voir
combien de fois pour être vraiment
un bpa de 50 euros qu'ils peuvent donner
même mille fois c'est quand même un
doublé parce que c'est marrant je vous
vois j'ai 50 balles on y voit là j'en ai
bien j'en vois vous venez me voir avec
50 euros je te demande ton photo date de
naissance quand on te prénom tiens je
fais la consultation pour toi et puis
voilà elle à la consultation c'est quoi
je vous demande par exemple voilà j'ai
une grosse soirée samedi j'ai besoin
d'être beau gosse
je ne suis pas sa
variante si je vous dit si vous dites
voilà ma meuf qui est partie j'aimerais
la récupérer il ça prend combien de
séances voilà
anticiper sur gilles gomez il a expliqué
moi je travaille pour protéger les ans
les inquiète leurs femmes et partir à
bord de même puissance sexuelle à quoi
monsieur a dit de l'avant des appels
tous
nos taux et tous voient la protection
contre les accidents de la route mais
dut tout voilà c'est ça c'est pas servir
si demande moi je vous dis voilà ma
femme est partie j'ai envie de la
récupérer il faut faire combien de
séances pour qu'elle revienne sur la
science avec 50 balles ma femme non non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vers 20h10 sexe à la maison c'est la
jolie
50 euros pour la consulte en
consultation d'accord le travail n'est
pas comme ça mais ouais 50 euros à
chaque fois qu'on a un problème c'est à
dire là ma femme est revenue ça y est
c'est plus un problème comme attention
au problème jemma lowe coucougnettes
50 balles tu te rends tu es parti quoi
elle forme ses accords d'accord très
bien d'accord je suis déçu oui je suis
peut-être je vais défini que moi te
vieux combi oui bah oui moi c'est
l'escroc senes qu'on a une chance sur
deux qui gagnent pas de ta femme
reviennent à hilton chaussons de qu'elle
revienne en prenant quand tu n'as pas
jean ba oui toute petite baisse pas de
sa marge brute mais ça va il dit
n'importe quoi
tu devrais utiliser le mal
alors je
suis prêt de livres à l'extérieur comme
lara gut on verra si je vais mal tu veux
te dis
juste qu'on appelle occultes donc
normalement on doit pas le savoir bien
sûr aucun surtout quand on fait du mal
enfin moi c'est ont pas songé chose que
c'est pas du tout
donc moi je fais que des choses
positives et occire j'utilise aussi la
prière selon ma religion dormi mais
voilà ça veut dire qu'il faut faire
attention aussi parce que par exemple
quand on commence à vous demander des
sommes folles ou des sommes très
importantes
là on peut dire que l'escroc tiendrait
viendra pas nafi par expérience gens me
jacques aymes te dire à mes 15 ans
j'étais recouverte d'eczéma c'est à dire
tu me reconnais c'est un pacte de non et
hop 6
juin
alors c'était de l'eczéma et pendant
toute ma jeunesse j'ai l'eczéma à 15 ans
vraiment un pic j'étais recouverte je
suis allé chez un magnétiseur il m'a
imposé les mains pendant une heure le
lendemain je me suis réveillé avec sept
pôles annonces sont pas vraies ainsi à
huy salaire pour les gens tournent parce
que c'est là qu'on va voir magnétiseur
on à votre côté
mais ce qui fait aussi beaucoup c'est
les coupes qui n'arrive pas à avoir
d'enfant est infertile ils viennent
damien
parce que ça n'a rien avoir été remanié
tisse alors
vraiment à la sorcellerie parce que en
2010 franchement j'étais au top de ma
carrière j'ai tout allait bien et j'ai
acheté une maison j'ai acheté une maison
j'étais beaucoup de travaux d'enquêté et
six mois après j'ai concerts de groupes
rem de pognon et un an après j'ai
terminé il trouve que la personne à qui
je l'avais achetée était très pressée
devant de la maison elle partait pour le
costa rica j'ai découvert qu'en fait
elle était elle aussi en fait totalement
ruiné et jc quand même curieux ccippp si
l'on sait c'est bizarre que l'on soit 2
avoir fait faillite monsieur pleureuses
et ce sur la maison ils trouvent que
celui d'avant avait aussi fait faillite
j'ai quand même ça n'a pas le même
ticket comme moi je devrais en manger
j'ai vraiment été totalement dans la
merde et j'étais contraint avant de la
maison la personne qui va racheter la
maison était le numéro 2 de altis énorme
groupe donc millionnaire simao -
celui-là d'ici là j'ai de ma maison il
n'arrivera jamais rude et le gars qui
venait un jour en fait rare et un jour
en aston esterra et il achète la maison
six mois après il meurt d'un cancer du
cerveau non et là je le dis alors cette
baraque franchement ccc c'est très
particulier et comme j'avais réussi
j'étais content pour lui à ce que mon
garde du corps travaille avec lui arnaud
un jour m'appelle mais vraiment paniquer
ni je viens de trouver une boîte qui
étaient enterrés dans le jardin qu'une
photo en noir et blanc de la maison avec
ses deux collègues et d'anglais et des
fêtes de patek des dép taches de sang
edit je pense que la maison était
ensorcelée et je pense que cette maison
a mené le match on sait que faisait
franchement il y avait 3 3 fois
consécutive et la personne qui rejette
après qui pouvait pas faire faillite
meurt alors hazard s'est acheté la
maison
si on regarde mes yeux fait selon moi je
crois que ces jeunes gens tombent
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si c'est bon ou pas mais
sauf que quand même c'est quand même
bizarre que tous les personnages et une
maison et vécu un drame alors maintenant
de profits sur l'image c'est possible ça
ça c'est possible parce que aller et à
des sources de la vie à des poisses avec
l'entente à roland et la maison et à
certaines des marabouts et sandy et à
des femmes aussi quand les pouilles tu
vois pas avoir la chance la forme nation
la mairie il ya des femmes pour les
chances et les femmes qui portent
malheur ils
s'engagent à la femme comme ça et à la
voiture comme ça et encore 10 heures à
la maison la voiture est la femme la
femme pas toutes les femmes n'ont
alors plus touchés par le sida qui est
une épouse j'étais en galère inquiétudes
d'un ton galère définitivement mais
c'est vrai il ya les enfants aussi à
marquer ou pas folichon que les enfants
ça m'énerve quand on
[Rires]
sait
qu'ils soient l'âge et moi je voulais
faire l'appel à la famille des pauvres
bah oui alors ça c'est bien oui
son frère et sur mer egée même père mais
c'est le frère même sans assez de même
voilà voilà après le jura qu'avec voilà
c'est le grand père paternel donc voilà
donc ici actuellement c'est la maman qui
souffle ses savons que ces règles le
problème a mis à blum à le problème là
s'arrête ici parce que si la famille
désire c'est pas bon mais moi je connais
pour barrer la d'expérience et les
croyants et la de bunkers et doit
comprendre son frère sont pour son frère
aussi il doit comprendre son petit frère
comme servant à faire au match
vous pouvez les aider vous par exemple
est-ce que vous pouvez apaiser tout ça
oui vous avez essayé il faut vous voulez
vous devriez voir depuis l' affaire a
commencé moi je fais la prière pour la
famille n'a pas ce qu'on vient à la même
pays quand je vois pour voir à la télé
c'est ça c'est mon frère théo si on est
même pays de sées guinée lui vous êtes
je sais que vous êtes mariés vous oui
femme n'est jamais parti non
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez des membres de
votre famille qui vient de vous voir qui
vous disent voilà il ya toute race noire
par exemple et à 3 jours même pas quatre
jours bouvier wayne l'homme qui est venu
me voir et m'a dit ma femme est partie
ça fait de dire moi je fais mariée la
femme line afrique qu à elven ici on a
fait le papier et la haine enfants
nourrison et les parties le plus des
mois la famille a fait tout la famille
il veut pas venir maintenant messieurs
il m'a appelé les veniez me voir et m'a
vu des professeurs de vie votre
publicité dans l'internet donc je suis
venu te voir pour savoir si tu peux me
faire quelque chose parce qu'elle l'a je
laime je travaille dur ici on aura moins
en afrique pour qu'il va venir ici je
n'y a pas de problème après je fais la
consultation sur le demandait le nom d
el sadate des médecins et où je donnais
quelque chose quatre jours plus tard la
femme et revenir à la maison en la
personne ne m'écoute là aussi c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
je perds la personne est revenue très
dur [ __ ] elle avait oublié ses
chaussures
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai et s'accroît et voulu donner quoi
que vous l'avez donné quelque chose mais
quoi moi toujours car je sais le travail
moins de travail pour les gens vous
donnez un fait de grandes cadeau car
voilà vous vivez que de ça oui d'accord
vous ne lui est pas ça aussi je fait
notre travail vous avez commandé
consultations par semaine
ça dépend le temps à peu près quoi là on
peut préparer je peux faire la
consultation d'une consultation ni
consulté soient d'accord ça fait moins
de saignements d'énergie ou pas revient
si ça prend de l'énergie parce que
secrète déficit il faut prier la nuit un
chien voilà tu dois pas tous ces alcools
qui doit pas tuer la femme de quelqu'un
d'autre tout doit pas mener à boîte tu
dois voilà c'est très difficile tu dois
pas fumer parce que toi tu as des noms
de quelque chose à dire que vers
terminera jamais
jean michel maire michel mr à castaldi
jamais une roma raboussa c'est ça c'est
sûr oui oui moi je voulais poser une
question par contre je voulais savoir de
quoi vient le titre professeur parce que
j'ai l'impression que ça allait être le
discrédit sur toute notre profession
parce que on voit dans les boîtes aux
lettres est partout et des annonces et à
chaque fois ses professeurs pour les
professions de chuck
c'est intéressant c'est pour cela que je
dis ça dans tout le métier et à des faux
marabouts et à de vrais marabout il ya
des gens qui font ça pour juste chercher
de l'argent mais c'est nous
la fonction qui vous vous prenez c'est
ici le professeur et c'est nous c'est
pas la même explication pour nous le
professeur c'est lui qui connaît son
travail mais les acquis mais la
professeure et tout donc peut-être n'est
pas professeur professeur mail en train
de profiter pour gagner l'argent c'est
tout oui enfin quand les c'est un titre
que vous allez me frayer tout simplement
que oui aux gars de merde on plaide lui
aussi m m m nettement professeurs ou
professeurs ou bien m m6 houston vous
parliez si vous parliez cyril de
récupérer de faire revenir une femme ou
un homme il ya aussi des techniques très
simple que vous faites sans doute de
prévention notamment qu'une femme ou un
homme
parts et notamment par exemple sais pas
si vous pouvez rassurer agnel c'est plus
la prévention
c'est vrai que en mettant un petit objet
dans le lit ou en touchant les pieds
d'une certaine manière on peut éviter
qu'une femme parts par exemple ça se
voit ça c'est vrai oui oui c'est bien
sûr tu donnes quelque chose la forme il
m'aide à la maison ça va amener la paix
à la maison blom il bouge pas la foi
mais ils bougent pas ils vont se
comprend ouais alors moi on m'a touché à
une chose je voulais aussi vous poser
cette question
on m'a dit que souvent comme vous le
disiez c'est le village c'est la famille
qui
détermine si vous avez des capacités si
vous pouvez faire ce travail de
marabouts et j'ai très souvent entendu
dire que quand les marabouts quitter
leur village justement il perdait lordon
et qu'en fin de compte il fallait qu'ils
restent chez eux normalement
c'est moi toute la famille la santé nous
ça existe pas depuis 20 ans moi je suis
là je choisissais la famille avait t
elle était à des troubles
oui oui belle action en fait en ce
moment on en parle énormément pascal
affaires pop bas mais d'habitude c'est
un sujet qui est jamais les cas urgents
seront aussi rien des traités mais c'est
très très répandu toute façon ça dans
toutes les civilisations il ya les
chamans
mais surtout dans les archers les
artistes c'est très très répandue et des
artistes très connus comme david bowie
qui était obsédé par des rituels il ya
lana del rey qui essaie de jeter un sort
à trump avec ses followers il ya bjork
qui a été élevé là dedans faye a
beaucoup et moi même j'ai rencontré en
travaillant dans ce milieu beaucoup
d'acteurs alors je passe étaient des
femmes je sais pas pourquoi mais
beaucoup d'actrices qui avaient recours
à
la magie noire pour faire ça et là pour
tous les fans qui parlent aux arbres ou
sur ses pas
est-ce que vous c'est des artistes
il est artiste le footballeur le
comédien tout le diable de personnes
comme
en espagne italie portugal en amérique
ça marche partout pour nos
téléspectateurs avons construit gilles
on en est ou de la sphère poste bas donc
alors la sphère pokba donc qu'il y a
même bape et a appelé lui même les
frères pogba pour savoir ce qui se passe
réellement parce que comme il fait
d'habitude il veut avoir directement la
source les réponses des frères n'ont pas
entièrement convaincu comme il ya une
enquête ils ont pas beaucoup répondu et
par rapport à l'extorsion de fonds pour
lequel importe paul pogba a porté
plainte sa mère a été entendu et un
intendant de l'équipe de france a été
entendue parce que quand il avait été
chopé par des gars est menacée c'était
la veille d'un rassemblement de l'équipe
de france donc ça avance sur les deux
fronts front judiciaire et feront de
maraboutage on espère que ras des éclats
alors je voudrais dire il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de dérives aussi un haut niveau
des marabouts la vie on le redit dans
cette émission donc faites attention il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont
énormément d'arnac donc je vous dis ne
paient pas des sommes astronomiques ne
fait pas n'importe quoi avec les
marabouts que ça c'est vraiment le plus
important en tout cas ce soir et c'est
ce qu'il faut que vous reteniez le plus
un voilà je vous dis à plein de mecs et
moodie on va faire revenir notre femme
va faire revenir bonne voiture on va
faire évacuer les bateaux existants bcsa
voilà donc ça il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui font n'importe quoi n'y croyais
pas du tout aux guérisons c'est ça
exactement c'est que ces mouvements mais
sur ma foi je n'y allais pas merci en
tout cas